the Battle of the Somme project
and for the participants it is
primarily friendship friendship between peoples
this friendship which united the British
and the French in 1916 this friendship
which unites them today which will
only  the future still the friendship between these
young future students or young adults
mahendra we are going to build peace is
indeed in europe and in the world
and I believe that the meaning it is
indeed there
it is clear that it is an
incredible experience for  the students who will
allow them to mark them
definitively are students who in
15 years and they will remember all
their lives both the relationship with
two of the British students of their age
but also for the ceremony which
awaits them and which  goes deeply the
marks it is the tour de force to
succeed in bringing together 600 students with their
guides and that everything goes
really well the students are
getting to know each other and that
is really fantastic  stic and they are
going to have an exceptional time it was
interesting to see that young
very young students who do
not speak French very well speak
English to you who
have nevertheless managed to play together have spoken have managed to
build things together is  born in aubas that at the
start they also made an
artistic work with an artist from albert
so we tried to incorporate the life
of civilians during the first
world war because we often forget them
we also integrated and well  of course the
life of the soldiers and the
technical innovations during the war like the
tank
we started by writing certain
letters which make think of the war
which was lived in the sum and in order to
put ourselves in the place of the hairy ones who were
at the front
this goal said khalid shock external
saturday a woman either
it is very important not to forget
what happened since still
today even if in europe there is
no war but not very far from home
we still have the war it's very
positive that the french and the english
still make exchanges today
since we have a lot of towns for
example
albert albert's life was completely
destroyed during the first war and
that's the  city of birmingham which gave
oney for the reconstruction after the war w
wi
h that our pupils can estab
ish a link with the English pupils a lin
which will be on the long term so it is
a means of establishing a bridge between our t
o  cult
a bridge across the channel
i would like to know the life of
english soldiers i would like to know how to speak
english
in fact he